>>Hi, I'm Tom Duenwald, I'm
principal of Sammamish High School.
>>When I first came here
as principal Sammamish was
in a place of declining enrollment.
Things weren't working, the staff
came together and was thinking about,
"Well, what could we do to take
Sammamish to the next level
and really serve our students?"
>>Adrienne: We have been fortunate to
get a federal grant that's allowed us
to move forward with re-designing our
school to be a problem-based school,
wall-to-wall, in every
curricular area.
>>Tom: It's a significant
shift from what can be more
of a traditional teacher-centered
classroom to more
of a teacher-facilitated
learning process
where we engage students
in authentic problems.
High schools have been
very resistant to change.
I mean I think a lot of
high schools, you visit them
and it could be fifty years ago.
And I don't think it
has to be that way.
>>Adrienne: So in eight days the
school year is going to start
and before that we are
getting together for five days
of professional development led
by Sammamish teachers
for Sammamish teachers.
>>Teacher: How do I transform
my class from being driven by me
to students wanting
to take ownership?
>>Adrienne: PBL in a classroom is
students actively working together
to solve a problem.
The problem can be big or small.
It can be the type of thing that
they can solve through discussion.
they build a product around.
But, ultimately, it's students
trying to learn content
through the solution to this problem.
>>There is something to
students having the opportunity
to get together and deal
with real-world challenges
that makes them hungry for the next
challenge, that desire to come back
to the table and invest more
of themselves in the outcome.
We want to grow that feeling in them
over the course of these four years.
That's what gets them to
stay involved in education.
>>Jayesh: This idea that
the whole school is focused
on problem-based learning
is really powerful.
Fifteen years of teaching
here, I've seen quite a lot.
I'm good at what I do.
I would like to be better, I would
like to be a more effective teacher.
>>Adrienne: For an entire
school to go through this
across the board is a big, big change
in what we're seeing other
schools doing across the country.
>>Rob: Sammamish has always been on
the verge, we're a really good school
and we're on the verge, I think,
of always becoming a great school.
If there's something that's
gonna transform our school,
this is what it's going to be.
>>Adrienne: I want to congratulate
you guys for being on time.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Slow down, slow down.
>>The first day of school we're
gonna have a brand new crop
of freshmen coming into
some brand new classes
that we've never taught before.
We're hoping that we're gonna be
able to get them engaged early on
and help them see the benefits and
positives of problem-based learning,
but I'm anxious about it.
>>Rob: So I have to tell you-
we've got five teachers
teaching this class.
We've been working on it this summer.
So we're really looking
forward to it.
Your feedback is gonna
be important to us.
>>Jayesh: The problem has
to be authentic in the sense
that it has a resonance
with the students.
>>Student: One of the problems in the
ocean is that with the higher amount
of CO2, calcifying
organisms are decreasing.
We're testing to see how well life--
other life in the ocean lives
without calcifying organisms.
>>Alejandra: I found out that
corral reefs are being destroyed
with high CO2.
It moved me and I'd
like to change that.
>>Teacher: Does your gravel
ever get green and slimy?
>>Anna: Oh, yeah, Algae.
>>Anna: Especially in
science and math I feel
like the subject can get
a little bit overwhelming.
So that's why I like the
project: it's one step at a time.
>>Jainxin: At first I thought
project-based learning was a plan
by the government to
increase the class sizes
so one teacher could teach more
students, but after I worked
with it I realized it was a way for
students to connect to the material
and understand the
material in our own way.
>>Student: Okay, migration
patterns from rural
to urban: we know that one.
All right, rural is, like,
farming, agriculture, right?
And then urban's kind of,
like, where we live right now.
So you can, like, draw a
picture from someone, like,
in eastern Washington
moving over to Bellevue.
>>Karissa: At first I thought that
it might not be possible to try
to get all the content in.
But I've found that we can still
find that balance where maybe one
or two days out of an entire unit
I can kind of really lead them
down the content and
then they can take that
and better learn from one another.
>>Danielle: I get moderate grades.
But if it's, like, you
have a group project,
you're gonna have other people
who have other ideas besides you.
So you're gonna be, like,
understanding it better
than just reading something
by yourself.
>>Rosendo: Yeah, I have a lot of
friends who struggle with English,
because they either
just came in, like,
two years ago or just barely came.
So, like, if they're in a
classroom with a lot of lecturing,
not enough group time, they're
not gonna learn English.
>>Adrienne: One of the ways
that we're empowering teachers is
we're giving them time during the
school day to work with their
colleagues on curriculum
that make sense to them,
given what they understand
about the best practices of
teaching in their discipline.
We're saying, "Come out
of that locked classroom.
Come into community and
let's find a way that we,
together, can move forward."
>>David: Our project was to
create a aquaponics system
and we had several
people working on it.
In my case I was kind
of the team leader.
We had to learn how an environmental
system in the wild would work
and then simulate that with the
materials that we were given.
The whole creative process
kind of went in steps.
Two members of my group
who are kind of just, like,
the thinkers that would think,
"What if we could include this?"
Once those two came
up with the ideas,
it would go through another person
who was kind of like the designer
to figure out, "Oh,
how would we make it?"
And then it would kind of
go up to me and I would kind
of be like the final decider.
>>Jainxin: I think it's a great
thing that students have a choice.
So when we do project-based
learning we're allowed
to teach ourselves the material
in a way that we can understand.
>>Rob: Well, the current project is
called "The Scramble for the Arctic"
and as a result of the climate
change the arctic is getting smaller
and there's all sorts of resources
in the arctic that will be available.
And the question we've
posed to students is,
"Who should control these resources?"
>>Student: We're arguing
about the Northwest Passage.
>>Christine: I know.
We need that, too.
This would probably be faster
than the actual Panama Canal.
>>It helps you prepare
for the future.
It gives you, like, leadership
and really good cooperation
skills with your group members.
>>Kyra: I think it's
more interesting.
I don't like just reading
and having a test.
It's not fun and you remember it
for the test and then you forget it.
>>Kelsey: We had someone come
in, an actual client come in,
and choose which one
she liked the best.
>>Client: I appreciated how
thoughtfully you responded to sort
of the "client's needs," my needs.
>>Anna: It's not just
for your teacher
who sees your work all the time;
it's for a client who's
deciding whether to build it.
And so you really strive to do well.
>>Tom Duenwald: When the students
know that what they're doing
in the classroom has an
audience outside the classroom,
it really helps them
deepen their thinking on it.
And I think that is
pretty authentic in terms
of what the future work world holds.
>>Kelsey: I wasn't realizing how much
I was learning until the end of it.
I'm a better learner when
I can actually get my hands
on something and do it.
And I'll just remember it better,
because I'll have an
experience to attach it with.
>>Christine: We're preparing for,
like, a U.N. summit, just, like,
portraying it and how they
actually do it in real life.
>>Rob: So you should say, "Can
I have these folks come up
and then we're gonna
got to Al Jazeera--
Al Jazeera our first
live media link."
>>Rob: These are hearings about
who should control the arctic,
and what should we do when
this territory opens up?
They're playing the role of
countries, and indigenous people,
environmental groups,
multinational organizations.
This is a real-life
problem that's playing out.
>>Student: Not only is oil
drilling-- it's extremely dangerous,
but oil recovery is
nearly impossible in ice.
And this oil will not last for more
than three years according to studies
in the U.S. Geological Survey.
It's about standing up for
environment and families
and our future, and I
won't give up this fight.
>>Student: Thank you, Delegate.
>>Bruna: Do you understand that
if I could have a trade route
through the arctic, my shipping
to the US would be
cut two weeks shorter.
So I'm sorry, I will
not be supporting you.
>>Bruna: I was the U.N. ambassador
to China, so I was a big leader
and I was totally into it.
I feel like if this was to happen
in real life I could
potentially change the world.
And that's the kind of
stuff I really like doing.
>>Student: Even if there is a chance
that what happened in the Gulf Coast,
even if it wasn't by you guys or what
happened in Alaska from you guys,
could happen in the arctic,
it could be devastating.
>>Student: If everybody just
suddenly decided to drop oil,
regular people do not, like,
my parents and your parents--
do not have the means to just
stop and go buy an electric car.
>>Natasha: Everyone's really, like,
pumped up and excited for it and,
like, there's a lot of tension
also, because people are agreeing,
disagreeing, but I think
that's what's making it fun.
>>Student: ..to protect Oceania
we have the World Wildlife Fund.
We understand that you want to
protect the natural environment
of the arctic, both nature
and wildlife in the area.
However, we do intend despite
your beliefs to go forward.
>>Rob: That was great.
Really-- I'm really proud of you.
>>Rob: What we do in
PBL, it builds on itself,
so that these projects
become part of the culture
and traditions of the school.
We have a day where we look at the
presentations of other students.
We have a day where we're going to
debate what happens in the arctic.
The biochem folks, they
grow their own food.
And I know they as a class
have some kind of feast.
That's great.
>>Teacher: If you want some
of the tilapia that we raised,
get a little plate
and come over here.
>>Rob: What that culture says to
students is that what you bring
to the table is valuable.
>>Adrienne: As teenagers I
think often what they fight
against is a sense that
life is happening to them.
So we give them classrooms
where they help
to direct what's happening there.
They are important to this process.
This is not a place
that you can hide.
This is a place where we want the
best of you, we see the best in you,
now let's bring that out.